kind of like Queen's content which is just consistently awful.
Bro needs to find a new hobby. YouTubing for him.
>> Jesus point me. >> W I don't want to do the voice.
>> Needs to find a new hobby. Stop. Please stop. Please.
>> Oh god. W for pick is brain rot. Full stop. But then
again, Quimman deleting all criticism from his comments is peak
brain rot too. Can't stand being called out. Kenny weak.
It's just very funny that like these people are botting Twitter
and losing arguments had they have no concept of what's true
or false.
It was great. Uh Techone very upset. Um I was going to watch
this Gokanu thing. I don't know if it's appropriate. He might
not have any problem. Oh wait, never mind. Oh, I I was wrong.
I thought he was an I thought he was 15 minutes in. I thought
he was 15 minutes into his stream. I was like, "Oh, it'd be kind
of up for me to go 15 minutes into his stream and start like
rereaming him." like an hour ago. It's probably not a big deal.
See here he's uh
>> starts the video around here
on the tag time fan. >> Where is this? Does he have >> like
a Discord overlay or anything? >> So it stands for deny
>> spreading revenge is harassment. >> Can I join
too? I need to tell you something. Hey Brian the what do you
need to tell me? >> That must be around biggest pieces.
>> Here we go. Here we go. Let's go. >> Okay. All
right. Yo, what is that music at the end? Difficult to say. Certainly
not associated with any culture, religion, or ethnic group. Can
you hear >> I can hear you. I'll make sure I have you muted
on stream here so we don't have a voice.
>> Sounds good. >> All righty. All righty. So, um,
throughout the whole video and there's a lot of >> Bro,
do you have any thoughts in that uh bl tweet though before we
go into this? >> We're told Denim's one.
>> Yeah. It's just I It's just embarrassing, isn't it?
It's just like the gayest virtue signaling ever. >> I don't
like And yeah, it's the gayest virtue signal. And then he's like
he's like actually defending. He's like, "No, it was critical
to Ethan making the point that they're anti-Semitic." >> It's
like, "No, it's not. >> It's not critical." And they're
not even
>> Dude, it's like four layers away from being anything.
>> Oh, it's very funny. >> I I don't like I just
don't know how this guy is so full of himself and he's so stupid.
He's actually just so dumb, man. It's so
>> annoying. And that's the funniest part. That's the funniest
part. >> It's crazy. Like zero self-awareness
>> He thinks he has like a case of double down and he doubles
down to X8. I don't know if X8 saw the like I just posted the
excerpt. Dude, it's like a total throwaway paragraph about how
Hassan is like this famous guy who met with
for no reason. It doesn't help explain anything. It's like, oh
yeah, Hassan wants to genocide and this guy did. Also, this guy
worked with Okay. Also, >> they realize they're like just
totally doing her marketing for her. Like it is like outrage
marketing and they're >> getting outraged.
>> That's That was like >> Good job. Good job. Good
job. >> Yeah. Like I I'm perfectly happy amplifying this
and giving denims more marketing. Yeah. Cool. We love denims
now, actually. Okay. >> Actually, no. We support denims.
Denim's awesome. Hassan is awesome. We love denims and Hassan.
>> I don't know if I can commit to Hassan one yet, but
denims. Yeah, 100%. I'm down with >> I actually tried I
tried watching dude I tried watching an actual Hassan segment
earlier only to blow my brains out trying to watch this guy.
Holy just like what talking about as girl that he stops mid sentence
to start ordering food on his phone. It's like bro you are the
worst. You actually need to be you do need to be deplatformed.
No, you do. >> If I just knew about this they would never
let this into the country. Okay, get them out. Hold on. I got
one other I going to say about denims. I can't remember now.
Oh, aristocracy replied to me and I I just asked like one question.
She still hasn't answered me as far as I can tell. Find this.
Oh, mentions are like broken on Twitter right now. It's actually
so annoying.
Uh, let me go find this. I hope she'll answer cuz like she she
talked to
>> she like definitely replied at the one point here. Where
where is it? Where is it? Yeah, right here. Goes toward motive.
This was arguing with me. Why are there pictures of in a copyright
infringement lawsuit? goes towards motive. How does the picture
of Hassanis meeting speak towards Denim's motive? She doesn't
answer because the discussion is that they're part the discussion
is that they're participating in anti-semitism which motivates
their behavior and they use the corpses of dead kids to shield
themselves. No, that's your culture war conversation that has
nothing to do with copyright infringement, idiot. >> So
crazy, man. >> Like we can't even we can't even get to
the part of the conversation where it's like, oh, it's a strict
liability crime and proving their motive really means >> I
just don't know how it got so bad so quick. How did it get so
bad so quick? How did everyone go so insane? It's so
>> I think it had to do with like there was just no push
back and then they were used to shutting down any push back and
now it's like they're sensible like hey this is weird like they
just start yelling anti-semite or they just have no critical
thinking. They're just like a part of the wave, right? Moving
forward all the time. Uh I cuz I think a lot of it is the reactions
to like sensible criticism are what like set off the alarm bells
so hard. Just when they're like talking in an empty room, it's
hard to get a picture of like how unhinged it is.
Yeah. We'll see, man.
Some goofy stuff. Oh, also
just like at a base level, this is my first take I did. Yeah.
Like um like why would she not use the most unhinged and most
iconic photo from that lawsuit like Paige? >> Yeah. Exactly.
Yes. Yeah. It just >> it's like what does this is this
going to get her any money or >> it Yeah. Lights one. Yeah.
Awesome. >> Yeah, IA
says Queenman is dodging him. I would love to platform a Tiska
versus Queman uh what do you call it? Debate, but probably not
on stream because I don't want to, you know, the your ship so
badly right now. But >> J one day. Okay. >> At some
point. Yeah. Um
wait, do you know do you know about SpaceX? Uh SpaceX's like
rocket
>> Oh yeah, it's important. Tyco, we'll let you know when
you do debate him. Okay. >> One of the biggest pieces is
that
um Techone has done everything. He's >> you know the craziest
thing that I had like a interaction with him where he was
and was like desperate for attention very clearly and he just
denies it ever happened like legacy was there. Legacy was laying
into him but just being like desperate for attention just constantly
repeating himself and and he just does it. He just like completely
says it didn't happen. It's so crazy. I don't know how people
get away with this even in Discord. Just saying something didn't
look I remember very clearly you were getting mocked heavily
because you were incredibly VC and and begging for attention,
begging to be spoken to basically constantly. I can't remember
what topic he was bringing up. He constantly kept bringing up
trying to start conversations about no one to talk about. He
just denies it. I just like pointing out the SpaceX rocket thing
because um you can point it out to him that he does it and he
will still do it in a conversation. He'll still like start bring
up bring it back to like oh SpaceX like >> brain damage.
This has got to be an actual like TBI patient or something. There's
not something not quite right. >> Is Quan talking to me
when I'm not here? W gaslighting? Let's go. All right. We getting
on Tao signs a little bit. Quan, are you okay? Are you suffering
from a schizotiple episode right now? What are you doing here,
buddy? >> You're doing crazy. You're insane.
>> I never said it never happened. Just that I don't know
what you're talking about. Oh, >> what does that mean?
What does that >> Uh, you say
you say you don't remember the event. It didn't happen. It's
whatever. It's the same thing. >> I have no recollection
of that whatsoever. Could have happened. Could it have not happened?
Hard to say. God.
All right. Okay. Okay. Just to reframe this for you guys. We're
watching Gokaru went live. He's going to watch the Techone video.
He started it and a Techone viewer hops in to start defending
his online father. >> Um throughout the whole video, and
there's a lot of context missing. >> One of the biggest
pieces is that
um Techone has done everything. He's lived in Texas, moved up
to Canada, immigrated to Canada, or attempted to become a >> And
this can't be commentary. This can't be commentary on the Shimu
video, is it? >> I've got no idea. I didn't watch Start
this. I came in halfway through. Well, hold on. Hold on. Yeah,
but I think we're here when he first got in. I don't think he's
even spoken at this. Oh, can you hear me? >> I can hear
you. I'll make sure I have you muted on stream here so we don't
have a voice.
>> Sounds good. >> All righty. All righty. So, um
throughout the whole video, and there's a lot of context missing.
>> One of the big >> So, he goes on to say one of
the biggest Hold on is that
>> um Techone has done everything. He's lived in Texas,
moved up to Canada, immigrated to Canada, or attempted to become
a citizen, >> and then moved back to Texas to join
>> Throughout this entire time, he has essentially been
financially supporting FEM himself through his streams and
>> I'm sorry. Which allegation does this speak to precisely?
>> Yeah. What is this relevant to? >> I don't Okay.
Yes, we knew he had a >> A really awesome guy. I really
love Teong. You're really awesome. Okay. You can't you can't
just let go of him like abusing his wife and getting his new
ex girl his new girlfriend to accuse her of revenge pointing
her. You can't just excuse that. He took care of her for 10 years.
For 10 years.
Wait, also didn't Frame just have like a job high up at one of
these agencies. She worked for like gamers subs or something?
Frame has like a Yeah, she was at Mythic Talon. Frame had work.
What do you mean? Frame literally worked in that car ride clip
that you saw that was really bad. Yeah. Tech looks like an [__]
He found her literally cuddling with his assistant. >> Oh,
this is literally just proven. Oh my >> Oh no.
>> No, it's over.
They cry there. Actual tactone didn't cry there. >> Yeah,
I think before today we just had um I think we had like some
receipts, but it was like a little but it literally was filed
in the legal like paperwork like it was a part of the lawsuit
and Shimu went over it. So uhoh. same assistant he is that she
is getting married to. >> Okay. Sorry. >> Massive
massive amount of context there. >> Yeah, that would be
so bad if Shimu do you think do you think Goku knows?
>> So the Okay, so wait wait.
So the context of that car ride
>> it is publicly at that point it's publicly known basically
that Frame was like cheating basically like lightly cheating
or something like that or what's the >> that's the that's
the thing like Techone tried to keep his rel >> that was
not what he this most of it private but obviously he's a streamer
so there's not much he can do especially since she was tech support
for him. He's very technologically illiterate like he's not very
good with tech. Yeah he's not good with tech at all. He's dogged
with it. >> I see. Okay. >> But this guy is like
>> she was his tech. >> It's like a DJ, right? It's
like that just like they don't have a thought
Just makes me I see Red. I see Red listening to people like this.
Someone was just like total NPC. No internal monologue. Just
like totally sucks. This guy's absolute bot. It's just like so
annoying. It actually is one of the most annoying things in the
world. >> That that exhalation there you did. You were
like you just trying not to punch a wall. I could hear it. I
could feel it >> I was trying to say the [__]
Jesus
support for ages. Absolutely ages. And um there's plenty of occasions
obviously like in the prior clip where he was like I was abusing
her. It's because he was being codependent on her to do everything
that he didn't know how to do. Like that's pretty much it. >> It's
not too big. It's not too deep. This is really >> That
is I don't know if you guys recognize that. That is another direct
like verbatim techone narrative that guys when I say I'm like
abusive or when I say I'm like bad in relation it's cuz I'm codependent.
I rely on her for too much. We're like the same person. I don't know
if you guys remember this. I can't even remember if we watch
it in the Shimu video or not. It might be in there. But he does
say that. That's like verbatim how he says he like a quote unquote
abuses his wife. >> Not too deep. >> Okay. Um Okay.
with
the allegation that Frame was cheating on him. Is that at what
point is that public? Like when did that become known? >> So
during the divorce process, um the reason that it took so long
to get the divorce process going, they were already separated.
Uh she had him sign an NDA.
I don't know if you've ever heard somebody sign an NDA to get
out of a marriage. >> She had him sign an NDA. >> Correct.
Correct. She had him sign a non-disclosure agreement.
Is that true? >> Um, I think the NDA was supposedly they
said it was tied to the exit of the marriage. I believe we now
know it was tied to the to like I think possibly like settling
the allegation or something,
right? I think they might have signed a settlement saying, "Hey,
maybe it's a non-disparagement clause, too." It seemed like there
was something signed after the allegations in the lawsuit, but
I don't know if we saw that in the Shimu video. there's like
some kind of NDA sign there, but I don't know if it's tied to
somebody was explaining earlier that although like also although
there is um although there's no way to NDA somebody from reporting
a crime, you can say, "Okay, I you're signing an NDA. We're not
going to talk about this." So, public allegations wouldn't be
able to go through, right? So, you would be able to go to the
police or you would be able to file like a complaint, but you
can't
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. >> Yeah. So that would be possibly
like all Teone's really concerned about too.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Anyway,
>> to not disparrage her in any way. And that's why throughout
if you look at the history cuz I had to look through all of this
for months. >> He never said a single bad thing about her
and would constantly defend her and protect her and tried to
deflect things away from her even though they weren't on good
terms.
>> Even even in that even in that one uh Twitter post where
they said we're not >> I'm not even kidding you. like a
day or two after he posted everybody, let's leave Fre alone.
Let's go back to what we do. He he deflected it. Even though
Even though >> this guy so this guy so
Dude, I'm cringing so bad. >> Yeah, but if you got a DJ
to come and defend Destiny like trying to nuke his his wife on
the way out in their divorce, right? It's like the same line
of dialogue. >> Not on good terms, >> Still following
the
beat and score was was clearly not not enough. Okay. dignity
to still push it away. Like, no, don't do that. Don't do that,
audience. Bad. >> Mhm. Yeah, I get what you're saying.
>> That's That's a sign of integrity. That's a sign of
some dignity. Even if he didn't spark that because Pink did,
>> he still doesn't want her to be >> Wait, we're
talking about Spark that
>> Wait, I wonder why he basically made Frame or sorry,
why he basically made Pink think that Frame had revenge for them
then? >> I wonder I wonder why that whole thing happened.
I wonder why there was a police report that got filed and why
it's been covered up and not covered up. Why it like hasn't got
anywhere. >> You can't prove that. >> Wait, hold
on. Well, she alleged it and
she alleged it. He's the only one who could have given her that
idea. Uh he can come out and say she's lying in the other direction,
but I don't I don't think so. >> Is it is it literally
written in the court documents? I >> Well, it is. Hold
on. It is now a part of the court record, is it not? Sorry, I
was not paying attention at the end of the video for like 2 minutes.
It is though, isn't it? But it's not like proven. It's just uh
he said, she said. >> Um yeah, I think so. >> Okay.
Okay.
>> it is a part of court documents. >> All right.
Spark that. We're talking about uh Pink coming out publicly basically
ringing.
>> Okay. So, you are you are under the impression basically
that it actually was the decision of Pink to attack Frame that
it wasn't Tee kind of like wanting her to do that. So the the
purchase of the bra and stuff obviously that's a pretty intimate
piece of like clothing to purchase. Okay. >> And like that
would make sense like oh >> this guy knows he's purchased
a lot of bras. Okay.
>> They were already in process of divorce >> clothing
to purchase >> and the only way to enull a divorce is quite
literally by either having or like canceling it yourselves. You
have to deliberately go out of your way to cancel the divorce.
It takes a long time depending on how deep it is. And with Teone
being basically a millionaire at that point, yeah, like there
was a lot of assets to separate. >> Okay. Sorry. So, they
were already in the process of divorce when
um from what I can tell this controversy where basically Tee
basically decided not to hang out with Pink
>> on Christmas and in >> decided not to hang out
with Frame. He >> No, no, no. Techone decided not to hang
out with Frame on Christmas.
>> And instead hung out with Pink. Okay. And so at this
point, Techone has no like real true, you know, uh like needed
uh like loyalty or whatever to Frame because they're already
initiating a divorce. Is that right? >> Correct. Yeah.
And that was well that was well after the car ride clip and that
was well after finding out that um she was with his assistant
at least to the slight degree. And if you have an inkling of
cheating, you have an idea that there could be worse. Right.
So, okay. So, this this is >> not true. Is that how you
run on the timeline? Are you sure? >> Yeah. No, that's
uh Yeah, obviously the curs guy didn't even meet her until well
after that clip. Like they they literally it's in the documents
like now it's it's timeline. It's chronic uh chronologically
laid out in the court documents as well. So, we only had like
the the basically people's like public testimony, but now it
is sort of proven out via the I mean, I assume if they're putting
stuff in in a complaint in a court document that that's going
to be an accurate timeline of events. And Teone's never even
disputed it, by the way. So, I don't even understand why these
people I don't understand how they could possibly be uninformed
on this. Tecton's literally never Well, probably because they
only watch Teone, but he's never even disputed it. It's not even
like a >> They're just willing to lie for, you know, for
him and to themselves about like what's happening because they
want to support him as well. I mean, it is
>> Yeah, it is. It's not even It's like, well, I know that
he's like a good person and so yeah, even though this like isn't
strictly correct or in line with my morals, you know, I can get
away with it. I got to help him. Okay, he's under attack. >> Okay.
Uh I'm trying to get a decent timeline in my head. So, at what
point do they Okay, first of all, first of all, when did they
get married? Are you familiar with that? Like, how long were
they actually married? He claimed 10 >> They they met like
they met like they met like years ago in League of Legends and
moved up. It was a 10- year long marriage. He was 18. >> Yeah.
Okay. And by the time of that clip, he was around 27
28 close to >> So like Yeah. 10 years and then the marriage
finally gets done. Like it's it's dusted. >> And um how
old is she? >> I believe she's only like a year older than
him at the time. >> Okay. And um >> a year older
at the time. >> At what point are they initiating divorce?
Is that 2023 or 2022?
>> The initiation of the >> just at that one specific
time. Most other times they're they're way different distance.
Okay. >> It's two years now. That's two years >> Boris
was just prior to uh 2022. If it if it wasn't, it was early 2022,
but like there's so much that went on behind the scenes,
>> And Pink Pink had that video uploaded initially. You
I don't know if there's a reupload of it anywhere. I was hunting
for it cuz I needed to get it for context and it was gone. When
you say
>> um the in in the video you're watching right now, there's
a there's a bunch of sections where Pink is exposing the um the
the creepiness of Frame, right? >> Yeah, the Frame is >> that
specific video is missing. It's >> When you say missing,
it's like you're saying the VOD, right? Like did she upload the
video to YouTube as well? >> She she Yeah, she uploaded
the video to YouTube as well. And the VOD is gone, too. Like
she deliberately deleted it. And the reason she deleted it was
because Teone broke up with Pink a little after. >> Good
boy.
Uh, one second. >> Can someone who grew up as the daughter
of a parillegal surrounded by lawyers and judges who actually
know how contract and family law works give context to how divorce
filings and >> Please leave. >> Why? Why is this
TTS me why is it so long and how an NDA is so right for how he
treats super chatters? Why actually just need this guy in
Okay, interesting.
okay. So, all right. So basically what I'm understanding is the
way you're presenting it to me is that um okay frame
potentially basically softerly I guess you could say was at least
signaling the idea of cheating on
eventually a divorce is initiated probably due to many reasons
but that being potentially one of them >> that could have
been like a straw that broke the camel's back. Yeah. >> Yeah.
while they are um initiating that divorce, Tee moves on basically
to Pink and
eventually while they're actually in an overt relationship like
Pink and Tactone. Um they I sorry I shouldn't say they you're
claiming that Pink of her more or less of her own valition decides
to publicly uh out I guess you could say uh Frame for creepy
behavior effectively being a stalker whatever she filed a police
report
and
now that Pink is no longer dating Techone she basically has gone
back on all that and she's against Teone again and she deleted
the video where she was on frame. Is that right? >> Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. >> She's very She was very bitter about the
relationship ending the way it did >> and so she broke
it off and >> bitter spiteful cut too. Something's got
to be done, man. Something's got to be >> There's like
legions of these people too. This is actually okay. If >> if
there is anything, you know, the whole lonely male discourse,
if there's any reason to believe in it, like this is the number
one symptom of the problem, okay? Is like people following Asmin
Gold.
It's
[__] >> bitter. She ends up going to what she
thought was her enemy and is now her friend and it just twisted
everything >> It's hard to trust Pink in the current state
because of how she's acting is straight up jealousy. Even though
Teone's trying to just move on and away from it and dude, even
though Teone is so kind that she like violated his privacy and
accus all he wants to do is move on. And he's so kind. He's so
considerate of her. He doesn't even say anything. He just kind
of bears it like kind of like a Christlike figure. And he's just
he's being so kind. Dude,
this is jealous. All right. She knows she [__] it
up. And >> dude, I'm actually
This is so bad. This sucks. I'm losing >> It has We have
to listen to it. Okay. You need motivation. We need motivation
to continue continue the good work. Okay. This is what we're
fighting for is for these people to >> to be so embarrassed
of themselves that
their social media profiles. Yeah, >> That because of like
>> that they delete their social media profiles, they buckle
down in their life, they get a job, they get they go to the gym,
they actually turn their lives. Okay. That's how their conduct.
>> That's why we want to say >> for all of these
people. Yeah, exactly. >> Several reasons. Some of them
being like personal like she's crazy or whatever the hell he
says, >> I don't I don't really know the particulars of
that. That's just sounds >> someone in my chat just asked,
"How can Goku stand this?" I think it's possible that Gokaru
doesn't really know the timelines either. I don't know if he
does. He's not looking into it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. He might just be looking into it now. So like
if if he doesn't know them at all, then he's probably just going
to be like, "Oh yeah, I'll probably like some very intelligent
people. Some very very intelligent people think this guy's like
a creep and a weirdo and that he's a total coward." So I'll look
into that and then I can bring this guy along for the ride. We
can figure it out together. But I think he he probably knows.
Okay. He's probably seen some tweets from people. probably is
a good idea. >> Personal experience, >> he didn't
want to be with her,
>> she got angry, got upset, and made a ton of allegations,
>> including like Techone is a and it was
>> Yeah, I know. It was massive.
>> Sorry. Pink is claiming that Tech >> Yes. Yes.
Exactly. Yes. >> Okay. And
what I was just watching in the Shimu video was basically that
Shamu is revealing
court documents
that basically hint at
um
Supreme preparing to publicly present a document that would implicate
techone. Is it known what the like actual accusations would have
been that were >> that document that you're seeing? Um,
but I don't know if it's further in the video. If there is one
further in the video here, I haven't seen this video in particular.
That document was the >> No, it's not. Why? Why did he
Dude, what? He's just brazenly making things up now. Or cool.
>> The divorce proceedings. >> I love when my divorce
proceedings say that uh Sodapoppin,
Cuckoo, and uh Vibbe are all witnesses to abuse, right? I love
it when my divorce says that. It's so cool. It's very relevant
to my >> Okay. Wait. All right. Whoa. Whoa. Okay. One sec.
One sec. Sorry. You haven't seen the Shimu video or you like
>> I have not seen the Shimu video, but the only reason
I I clicked on it is cuz >> By the way, it's a Google doc.
Wait, it's a Google doc. What am I even saying? Right. It's literally
like a Google doc of allegations. Like meant to be public allegations.
That's the document we're talking about, right? With the the
sodapoppin.
I I feel like if I'm not misremembering, that's a Google doc
that's referenced in the
lawsuit in some lawsuit. I followed you from the um Sneo video.
>> I still had you subscribed and you popped open the tech
as a coward. I'm like, "Oh, I've researched this guy." God damn
it. Yeah. >> I popped in your chat and I immediately came
out with that. >> So autistic you can hear it. So go damn
it. God damn it. You can just hear it, man. I I >> Oh no.
Another person thinks that TeeOne might be bad when they don't
realize that he is essentially Jesus Christ himself. Oh my. This
is not good.
Dude, what are you looking at? Because
>> a lot of people and I I'm gonna say >> I've researched
this dude. >> Hey, this everybody in chat can probably
agree. Techone is an absolute a lot of the times. He's an exaggeratory
but that doesn't mean that he is guaranteed to be the worst person
on >> Okay, pretty sound like
>> it's it's it's actually haunting, isn't it? Dude, >> I
think I get what you're saying, which is basically like this
guy's a and it's probably easy. easy to smear him, but don't
take it too far because there's more to it. Is that what you're
Okay. >> Yeah. Exactly that. Yes. Because I've I've I've
know people don't like like Asmin Gold. I know people don't like
Techone for their own reasons. >> It's one thing to say
like, "Oh, I don't like him. I don't like Asthma Gold because
he's unclean. Why should I take his advice?" >> It's another
thing to say that because he's unclean and his mother that he
supports Adolf. It is ridiculous to make that extrapolation,
>> right? I get what you're saying. It's like, you know,
it's like a level of vitriolic that's you're giving them like
zero good faith or whatever. >> Yeah. Yeah. You're not
trying to argue on the pretense of like >> I don't know
what's going on. >> I think I'm mad. I'm not angry right
now. It's not good. >> Uh listen, we're on kick. It's probably
not that bad. It's probably okay. >> Know what's going
on. To create my own conclusion that like I'm not even kidding
you. I didn't know who Tee was until the Steak Eggs podcast.
>> Yeah. by investing. >> Oh, he's an as he's either
an asmin gold or he's an Emmy reviewer. Which one, guys? Hold
on. Do we have a Do we have a mod in chat? Can I get a poll in
this right now? Is this guy originally an Asmin Gold viewer or
an Emmy reviewer? Or both? One, two, or put both as option two
and Emmy is option three. It's totally unrelated to anything
else. Um, >> him because his stories about Genchin Impact
sounded embellished. It turns out they were embellished and they
were against him. They were all accusing him of like
>> we're Iron Mike fans here. Okay. >> Information
and wrongdoing. Like him being a him being a racist, him being
like an abuser. >> There's
Yeah, I think this guy, man,
this guy is like this is actually another case of like total
mental, right? Like this guy is actually cognitively.
Like he's just he's like making up allegations that haven't happened
at all. Yeah. It's >> Dude, it's crazy. >> Ridiculous
how wild they went. >> Okay. Um All right. Do you want
to watch this video with me?
>> I I will be willing to. Yeah, you're you're streaming
it to me here on the left on Discord. So, yeah, I got you. >> Yeah.
I uh I am curious to
because I am actually unironically a total techone noob. Um,
and so I'm realistically not the correct person for you to talk
with about this, but I appreci like it's good to get high counter
perspective. Dude, I would love to talk to this guy. >> I
appreciate the cander that you have in >> Oh, God.
No mean and which type their documentation was. Also, can you
ask him what his understanding of Daro is and why his opinions
expressed here exemplify why abusers earn sympathy?
uh ask your expert witness if he knows what at fault and no fault
divorce means, which type of their documentation was. The problem
is that if there was any uh information in that documentation
that would have been indicative of a no fault or at fault divorce,
we don't have direct evidence to prove who did what or if there
was a no fault. But it's more than likely it's a no fault divorce
because they both agreed to do the divorce and there was an NDA
signed because Teone was not allowed to speak about Frame in
a negative light in any way. And the only reason he recently
was able to was because Frame spoke ill about him and the documentation
on a on a live stream to Denims. >> Damn. And the lore
goes from the Holy
>> Hey, is that how Wait, that is kind of how uh that's
kind of how I don't even know what he's talking about. That frame
is on I feel like I would have seen frame on a denim stream,
right? >> Yeah, I feel like I would have seen >> But
also, um is that actually how NDAs work? Cuz Dr. Disrespect did
that same thing, too, didn't he? He was like, "Now, now that
Twitch has leaked my my allegations, I can talk about >> I
can finally talk about it." Yeah. It's >> is that is that
how they write NDAs? I would just think you like have the right
to sue the other party. I don't think it necessarily gives you
the right to violate the NDA, too. But maybe,
>> but like wouldn't you want that litigated first before
you violate the NDA and then you realize that like a judge thinks
they didn't violate the >> No, technically just that guy.
>> I don't know. Whatever. >> that that's the only
reason he's >> If you write it that Yeah, I agree. You
could write it that way, but then you'd probably want it litigated
first before you breach the NDA. You probably wouldn't just want
to go, "Oh, I think that's a breach." and go >> able to
do that. >> Only reason. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's
Let's watch this, I guess, together. I just cuz uh if it's okay,
I'm not going to buy into what you're saying fully. I'm just
>> guaranteed, man. That's good. >> I'm just trying
to It is useful to get a counter perspective, especially I literally,
dude, I have I really don't have context for this guy. like like
the title itself, Twitch mo Twitch's most abusive liar is straight
up indicative of like this guy wants to show how bad he is. >> Yeah.
Well done. Well done. Well done.
>> He did his investigation, guys. He's spent a lot of
time researching this guy. Damn.
>> My video it was just a retrospective look back. What
did he do?
Right. Yeah. >> Yeah. I get what you're saying. Like this
is a hippie. This is what you're saying basically. Yeah.
>> Okay. All right, let's go. Let's get it >> later.
But it's important to realize that the attacks Pink made prior
is a direct response to Teone finding out through Pink that Frame
was going to go public with the alleged abuse she went through
with Teone. I reached out to Techone to get his side of the story
in any context I could. At first, he said he was happy to answer
any questions until he realized how meticulously I had gone through
everything. I asked him what the allegations were that Pink mentioned
were going to ruin all of their lives, not letting him know I
already had the court documents proving what they were. And he
lied to me. He said, quote, "No allegations were going to be
made against me. This is between her and another woman." Probably
a lie. to me. >> Okay. So, what am I missing something
from that? Is the
>> Yeah, let's pull Let's pull the documents back up here.
He goes through them rather fast. I don't know why he burns through
it so quick. >> Let's see. Okay, so
he he knows that we all have a pause button. I think that tends
to be the pace that Shimu goes at is he's telling the story and
then he basically allows you to pause if you want to read deeper
into the documents. He'll like summarize them. I haven't seen
him summarizing them in like super bad faith at any point, but
he knows we all have a pause button. We can pause and read it
ourselves. >> Allegations were that Pink mentioned were
going to ruin all of their lives, not letting him know I already
had the court documents. Prove >> Sorry. Okay. >> Oh
man, I got I got fast on it. >> Okay. Uh Pinky Tube reached
out to Okay, this guy who had promised to issue a public apology
to Pinky. However, they explained that her understanding of the
dispute between free and are commonly court ordered by judges
against people who have documented physical and violence against
their partner in an attempt to for divorce to discourage further
harassment of their victim. >> You cannot you cannot force
people to sign an NDA and you cannot prevent them from speaking
out because the speakout act. So if she was >> wait the
speakout act. What's the speak out act? The Speakout Act is an
act of Congress which prevents the enforcement of non-disclosure
agreements in instances of assault and harassment introduced
by Christian Gillbrand blah blah blah blah blah. One of the me
too movement's primary targets was the enactment of non-disclosure
agreements. Wait, what? Oh, which me too leaders saw? Hm. Because
I would have thought you couldn't NDA crimes, but maybe this
says you can't NDA people from going public
after this stuff. Uh, that's a reasonable counterargument.
I will say though, unfortunately against this, I think a lot
of people just don't know that a lot of NDAs are uninforceable.
They like sign a legal document or something and they just think
they're like bound by it forever
>> and arrest it without challenging it. >> Yeah,
exactly. >> If there was assault to Pink, she would have
been able to speak out about it and she would have been able
to go to the police about it. >> Wait, but this is Fe speaking
out, >> She said she had evidence, but she didn't do anything
for months. That was the problem. Like I was all for pink. Do
it like >> Oh, bro. I want this guy. I want Goku to ask
this guy. What do you think evidence of like a forced [__]
would be like months later?
What? What? What evidence is there? >> Proving that Teone
was what she said he was, but she didn't. >> This is Okay.
So, Pink accused him of being arrested, right? >> Correct.
Correct. >> Okay. Is how specific has she gotten in the
accusation? >> Specific as in like she's said that >> did
she provide like a tweet longer? Has she like talked about it
in like a live >> It's essentially it's essentially Twitter
posts. Yeah, I think their Twitter posts for those are still
off, >> Okay. And is it just an implication? Is it an overt
accusation or >> It's essentially a description of what
she recalls the events to be. So, it's it's it's a hearsay at
this point. >> He says no, she says yes. >> Okay.
That's not Hold on. Hearsay is explicitly not first party testimony,
>> I hear people keep using that word wrong recently and
it drives me crazy. It's just like one of those. Yeah. >> So,
what proof do you would you like kind of think that she could
provide? Has she claimed she has proof or what's
>> that that's the thing. She stated she has proof, but
we have like obviously we shouldn't be able to see it if it's
going to court, but she hasn't gone to the police about it. She
hasn't gone to court about it because there hasn't been a file
on it. >> I need proof specific case. >> That's a
call back. Epic call back. >> Oh, that's when was the last
time you checked for that?
Last time I checked for that was during my investigation and
then after my investigation because the during was for Frame
after it was when Pink came out and stated that and I was like
looking and Teone was waiting for months to receive a report
from the police for a summon or anything. Nothing. >> Oh,
so this guy is just totally unaware that Teone is also saying
that he can't comment on these things because of an ongoing police
investigation that I guess nothing. >> Okay. All right.
Um Okay. The dispute
>> Yeah. The dispute between Freem and Teone relates to
a serious and false allegation against Teone. So, okay. This
is from the divorce filing. Is that >> This should be from
the force divorce filing. Yes. >> Okay. And >> however,
actually, wait, no, no. February 2024. It's well after the divorce
filing. >> Okay. So, then what what is this? Is >> you
can essentially create a court document to start something, but
if there's nothing continued from it, there's nothing continued
from it. We don't even know if this like if this could happen
in like 2029 at this point if it is a an actual case but we haven't
gotten anything. We haven't gotten a single thing from Pink and
Fe has come out and basically unulled the NDA that she enacted
on did not disparage her.
>> His side of the story in any context I could. At first
he said he was happy to answer any questions until he realized
how meticulously I had gone through everything. I asked him what
the allegations were that Pink mentioned were going to ruin all
of their lives. Not letting him know I already had the court
documents proving what they were. During that call, Techone and
Pink learned that Frame had a Google doc that she was planning
to release to the public. And so, sorry, do you know what this
case is or what the hell this filing is or the court documents
he's referring to? >> During the contact, you learned that
Free had a Google doc that she was planning to release to the
public. This is essentially the um you you've seen plenty of
people drop Google Docs before on other people, right? >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> Yeah. And it's it's a massive pile of Oh my god.
>> either evidence or nothing. >> Yeah. Yeah. She
didn't she didn't drop anything
because of this court filing. She probably was told not to drop
>> right? Well, yeah. Like to jeopardize the case or whatever
or why? >> Yeah, it it might jeopardize the case. It might
bury some information. It might make some information invalid.
That's why I stated if this court uh if this comes out to be
true that like Tech's allegations were real, it would probably
end up going to criminal court like straight up because Teone
would be, right? Like that's that's how it would be. But this
case is like what been submitted for I think two years now. Nothing
has happened. >> Sorry. Tres
one year now. Nothing has happened. Like >> hold on hold
on hold on. This case has been submitted for two years. Oh, he's
talking about the frame one. The frame one I don't believe is
being pursued. I don't think anyone's arguing the frame one's
being pursued. And then if it's the pink one, it can't be for
two years already, can it? Maybe it's coming up on two years.
What is it? 2023 November. Yeah, Mike's on. I'm actually not
sure. Okay, hold on. I'll hit >> I guess could happen in
2029. I'm willing to be proven wrong because, you know, I don't
want somebody who's like that to be out. But >> as it stands,
we we have nothing.
>> Compel you to sign an NDA under threat of being held
by the court to not publicize the details of a victim's physical
and abuse. If there is a court order, it is not hearsay. The
existence of court orders proves the victim's >> The Okay.
The NBA was in regards to the relationship between Teetone and
Frame. The abuse that Teone claims he suffered was emotional
and like it was it was specifically emotional and somewhat like
financial a little bit he thinks, but I mean he's rich as he
didn't really care about that part. The NDA was specifically
between those two. >> Bad boy. >> Goka, please show
the viewers the video, too. Your face is nice, but it would be
nice to see.
>> That's actually pull the video any stake in the Tecton
game, but I'm glad
facilitate like a at least something that I can watch back and
get a better understanding. Um, okay. Okay. Okay. So, what I'm
understanding. Okay. It So, pink pinky. Oh, guys, we are some
number of subs away from another hour on the stream. What do
we got? 18:30. We We're like eight subs away from another hour
on the stream. Go ahead, donate. If you don't, I'm probably just
going to keep watching this, so probably no downside to not donating.
Good luck. You >> is. Yes. >> Also, join the Patreon.
>> Court case, >> dude. I I usually make like most
of my donation goal in like the first hour of the stream and
then I just don't really It's whatever >> involving her,
right, with the >> It's whatever.
>> Yes. because she stated that there was cases of a tectone
committing sexual assault on her. >> Okay. So, and and
so but with this court case, we don't know exactly what it is,
but it's alluding to some kind of expo like expose effectively,
right?
>> Yeah. Where one person stating, "I'm going to release
a Google doc about this." Another person stating I have to file
a police report about this. There's no summons. There's no in
>> Oh, I'm trying to find the the pinky stuff. Can Does
anybody have this sitting somewhere? And if anyone has this sitting
somewhere, I would love to get it. Ah,
>> yeah. If anybody subbox society, thank you for the five
gifted. If anybody's got the the pink tweets, the first pink
tweets sitting somewhere, you link them to me. I'd appreciate
it. >> Investigation going on. Techone has not received
anything. And he's been blatantly open about every single step
of the way. And much like these documents, that should be public.
>> You should be able to see this in the >> right?
And um okay, so Frame is also accusing him of Is that right?
>> Frame is backing it up as an expert witness of sorts.
I don't think there's >> Okay, this guy's talking about
it for two years with with Pink, I thought. And November 22nd,
2024. I thought it was not even a year yet. And it's not okay.
Good, good, good to have that ironed out >> involved between
um Techone and Frame. >> there could be between Teone and
Pink. I'm not certain, but I do know that when you have a relationship
that with a high-profile individual and it breaks off, it's really
messy. We've seen the Johnny Depp and Amber Her thing. It is
very messy with the details and you if you get it wrong, everything
gets up. >> I mean, when you say get it wrong, you mean
like in reporting it or >> in reporting it? Yes. Like if
if Pink if Pink is saying this guy me when we were together and
I'm reporting this months in advance now their question will
come up in court. Why didn't you report this within a day? Why
didn't you report this within the hour? >> Why didn't you
get to the police? You >> wait. Does this guy not understand
that like you could be in a relationship have like a dubious
consent thing that you start like going over and you realize
like oh actually this has become a pattern and this guy really
doesn't care about my consent. It wasn't just like a mistake
and actually >> The answer to does this guy understand
anything about her relationship is probably going to be no every
time. Let's be serious.
>> You leave. >> Why didn't you and it's going to
it's going to it's going to go against her in that regard because
now she's >> if this man was really beating your skull
in, why didn't you just leave? Okay. I wonder if anybody's ever
asked this of an abuse victim before. Has anybody ever thought
about this guys? Why? How can you say this guy punched you in
the face multiple times throughout your relationship if you didn't
just leave the first time he punched you in the face? Are you
this stupid look at this stupid battered wife? It's almost like
we call it like battered wife something. Wow. >> Unreliable
for her own case because she reported it so late even though
she's stating, "Yeah, he did this to me here." She wasn't held
behind or anything. >> Is it a criminal filing or is it
a civil filing? Like >> it's a civil filing. That's the
problem. It's a criminal It's a It's a criminal accusation with
a civil filing. >> Right. Right. So, does he not realize
that there are probably overlapping criminal and civil penalties
for a lot of things and people can pursue either one first? I
believe this was what Cassie did, right, with Diddy? She pursued
civil before criminal. Now, why would you do that? It's it's
difficult to say. There's a lot of different reasons. I believe
you can usually use evidence from your civil trial at a criminal
trial if you want to do that, but there's like there's lots of
reasons you could maybe do that. Is the end goal to get like
uh in a ci okay I'm not that well acquainted with the courts
but the end goal on paper of a civil filing civil lawsuit whatever
is to basically receive uh basically so when you have a he said
she said allegation guys can you think of a reason you might
go to the court with a lower burden of proof
could you hm let's think about this well can I prove he my mouth
without a shadow of a doubt probably Not could I given like a
propensity of evidence like could I have given some amount of
evidence could I maybe convince them that there's a better chance
he he tried to like put me than not maybe maybe
right obviously the criminal burden of proof is way higher uh
beyond a reasonable doubt and then what's the other one it's
um preponderance of evidence not propensity I said propensity
it made sense in the context but preponderance of evidence >> compensation
for damages and whatever right um >> it could be compensation
for damages it a public apology.
I see >> anything of that regard. Anything to
basically either put Techone to justice or ruin his um career
cuz like if he if he is exactly what they say he is. Yeah. He's
going to lose thousands of subs. He's going to lose millions
of dollars over the course of the years and that's going to ruin
his >> based on what
why what evidence is there of that >> career? And I I'm
going to let chat know. I'm going to let Chhat know specifically.
I would agree with that wholeheartedly
if it is true. But we cannot jump to the possibility that an
is true until we have proof. That is the important part.
That's how the courts do it and that's how we should look at
it because the court of public opinion is easy to sway. And like
I've I've seen people in your chat stating that oh there are
people that are defending techone and I in my case it looks like
I'm defending techone. >> Yeah. Yeah. I hear >> guaranteed.
Yeah, >> guys, it looks like I'm defending Tecton instead
of just standing up for what's right and just in this world.
I know that I totally up the timeline with the cheating thing
in the car when he's being abusive to his wife. I know that I've
basically tried to point out any point where he's like the kindest
soul involved in all these stories. I know that I'm doing that,
but also it's not about defending Teone. It's just about for
standing up for what's right. Okay.
W night. >> Okay. Okay. Important question that's not fully
related to this. Is his dad
>> No. No. Okay, that is okay. That was literally that.
>> I'm a damn boy, >> dude. This guy
just keeps giving 10 >> Pull a Ron Swanson I know more
than you and ask this guy what he thinks a non-disclosure agreement
is and what NDA means. Also, why he is so comfortable siding
with a man that by all accounts is showing classic domestic abuser
and archetypy. We like to staple labels and to people that might
be acting erratically. The man has schizophrenia.
It could be more erratic to the point where you might be construing
certain things like that. It's not a archetype. >> So wait,
were you aware of this before the Shimu video today? >> The
man has schizophrenia. I think people really actually believe
that Tekone has schizophrenia. >> People believe. Wait,
really?
>> I believe he's saying or is he saying that Iron Mike
has schizophrenia? >> I thought it must be Iron Mike. But
Tactone has said he has schizophrenia and he talked about hallucinating
his dead friend's mom in that video. >> I thought it was
plazookas. Is he talking about
be acting erratically? The man has
The man has schizophrenia. It could be more erratic to the point
where >> Okay. Well, Goku is gonna I think Goku is going
to elaborate now. Ask to have this elaborated on because he seems
to have reacted. >> You might be construing certain things
like that. It's not a archetypy to defend yourself when somebody's
accusing you of rap. It's not. If if a woman goes down the street
and you brushed her shoulder and she points at you and say you
her, you're going to defend yourself and say, "No, I brushed
your shoulder. I'm sorry." Like, >> she's going to >> I'm
probably not going to go, I have proof that this is lying and
then disappear though,
right? Like there's some things that we can say are stranger
than others. >> You think that you have to defend yourself,
right? Uh, did you say Tekone has schizophrenia?
>> Correct. Yes, he has diagnosed
Yes. This is so much better than I thought it was going to be.
Oh,
dude. This is the guy who did the research, by the way. He believes
this, dude. Hold on. Hold on. You know who would know something
about this? Hold on.
Can we put schizophrenia in Plazooka's channel and find
>> My name is Plazookas. I got a reaction. He's doing a
reaction. He did a reaction to Shimu video. Let's go. Oh my god.
Oh. Uh-oh.
If it's not on here. I don't think that's something he's alleged
very many times or people take serious because if that were true,
I believe there would be a Plazooka's video about it. There is
no techone trait imaginable that there would not be a teazooka's
video about. Okay, that's crazy >> people because if he
lives alone, he starts seeing things. It's >> something
he stated repeatedly and commonly and I think I've seen like
two episodes of it when I've watched his streams here and there.
>> I I don't want I don't want to say it's false, but I
I can't confirm wholeheartedly it's true. I don't have doctor's
notes. >> Gotcha. Gotcha. That's >> But I can't I
can't >> I feel like there are other elements of schizophrenia
that make it incredibly unlikely that Teton is schizophrenia,
right? Like there are He said diagnosed. He did say diagnosed.
>> Pressured speech or anything like that. Like the idea
schizophrenic people you can usually tell they're schizophrenic.
>> Like and like there are just they're like social symptoms
that come up. Like basically oh man there's got to be there's
I guarantee there's a bunch of like second order symptoms that
he has none of that just it would be like incredibly suspicious
for him to have none of them. Anyway, I don't believe he would
lie about it doesn't feel like a joke like if it's not true he's
lying >> Yeah. He there was an occasion where he saw one
of his um his Discord mods had something called skin your face
off and he freaked out about it so hard that he had to he had
a mild panic attack and had to have uh his current roommate uh
current girlfriend come down to calm him down because he was
like I I I could have sworn I just saw somebody tell me to peel
my skin off and he's freaking out about it. >> It's I I'm
inclined to believe it is
>> because there's no reason he would just stop stream.
>> I will be real, bro. I do not tolerate disrespect towards
Dr. K. This is a this is a guy who genuinely chang
I didn't get the time stamp. I didn't get the time stamp. Hold
on. This one right here to my psychiatrist. First time I attempted
was due to the the the medicine that I was given for my schizophrenia.
I talked to my psychiatrist. He labeled me with schizophrenia.
I was very afraid. One night I took the medicine and turned me
into a zombie. I kept on being a zombie. I kept on being a zombie.
I kept on being a zombie to How did nobody pick this up? How
did nobody know about this? How is like this the first time I
put schizophrenia into the film mod search to see if it would
pop up? This is clearly not joking, by the way. This is like
clearly not a joke at all.
>> I
This is just so unbelievable to me. I I've seen schizophrenic
people before. They they have symptoms that you can that come
out when they're talking for extended periods of time. You wouldn't
be able to like be on live stream this much.
Your only schizophrenic symptoms are Oh, someone's telling me
to peel my skin off. I'm so scared. Like that. That's not >> uh
new word for schizophrenia.
As a guy who has schizophrenia, I'm deeply offended by this.
>> Do you identify, >> dude? It's so real. It's so
so real. Oh my god. Hold up. My internet's this film watch is
not really working, but it's fine. I'm just I'm just Dude, there's
so many clips. So many clips came up >> to my schizophrenia.
Yeah, probably. Uh >> hold on. What What is that one? Some
of you guys may know I wouldn't say I'm religious. However, I
do believe in spirits uh and u the afterlife and all that. Now,
is that mainly due to my schizophrenia? Yeah, probably. Uh but
religious extremism is and has always been a problem. And uh
you know, >> okay, I like I could see this being Yeah,
exactly what evil Johnny Bravo said. They're like schizoffective
disorders on a spectrum. I could see maybe he does experience
like some level of hallucination. I doubt it's like diagnosed
schizophrenia, actual schizophrenia that you are having like
severe reactions to. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like okay, maybe. No,
no, no, no, no. I Dude, there's so many indications here. Could
be well-medicated schizophrenia. I don't know about that.
I would wonder if he's on any medications for this given the
energy on stream,
right? But I also I don't have a great grasp on the medications
people would take and stuff. So like I could see him having some
kind of like um hallucinatory thing. Like he could he experienced
hallucinations of some kind, but I just don't think it's actual
schizophrenia where he's like this functional all of the time
to stream this consistently with no like and where are his like
um like his downturns where he has like a like an episode and
like actually crashes out and is gone. I would expect that for
sure, right? I may Yeah, I don't know. I'm speaking a little
bit out of my ass, but like, bro, I just can't see it. I'd have
to do like research now to know for sure. There are schizophrenic
people who don't have any symptoms while medicate. Okay, maybe.
Maybe.
I feel like I'm incredibly doubtful, but maybe. Anyway,
>> suddenly to do that. >> And then bring it up later.
It doesn't make sense. >> Okay. All right. Let's let's
prog
wait.
the dad thing because this video it we're just >> Yeah,
it brought it brought up his dad thing earlier. It >> it
it's a strong start. Let me just say that. It's a strong start.
It's a good hook, but let's >> Hey guys, please like on
the video as it helps the channel and the dollar sign both YouTube
and Twitch has spent the past year.
>> Sorry, I'm cooked. >> You're good. >> Do
the frame. That wasn't good, right? I'm probably going to >> Hey
guys, please hit like on the video. What I found was a man willing
to lie, deceive, and manipulate those around him. Sourcing court
documents I found. I believe this video will offer an exclusive
look into what has really been going on with Techon. And it is
not good. Is he documents? I >> Is this a pink frame? So,
there's a pink frame lawsuit is what he's pulling the docks from,
by the way. Not the not the divorce. It's the pink frame lawsuit.
>> I believe this video will offer an exclusive look into
what has really been going on with TechOne, and it is not good.
Is he guilty? Well, by the end of the video, you will at least
have some clarity as to how we got here. But you know what they
say, like father like >> I don't know what happens, bro.
Just bad follows me like the plane. You think that happen? >> And
why are you doing that? you >> tactone is the bread winner.
>> That's like saying you're going to make but not have
the money shot. It ain't there ain't a money shot. She looks
real submissive and looks like in the words of Holly I can take
a pounding. >> She was going to do something much worse.
So bad it would have ruined all of our lives. I'm not going to
say what >> how much was he bringing his dad on his stream
if you have insight. >> Not common. It is insane. It was
insanely uncommon that he brought his dad on streams. >> Okay.
And what he did was the dad like a gooner.
No, the so the dad was in the military and um he was a a more
higher ranking member of the military and he had uh something
on his phone. It was a it was a joke probably >> that's
not
oh he's just going to wholesale buy into what Te said the first
time. Okay, cool. something in in relation to a joke and he showed
it to some people in in his unit and somebody ended up reporting
him for it and he was um essentially like militarily convicted
of sorts for
uh
it was not assault it was like in >> it was assault it
was assault he's convicted of now was the stripped out I'm sure
you could look into that I'm guessing you could find records
on this but yeah >> appropriate behavior essentially but
He wasn't like dishonorably discharged. It was just like a what
the [__] dude. >> Oh, really? >> And
then like a slap on the wrist
>> Guess who that's an indictment of
he like military court system. Okay. He should have been dishonorably
discharged. It's pretty up allegations to be convicted of and
then them to just go, you know what, full rank full pension.
Get out of here, Mike. You rascal. Get out of here. Get out of
here, you rascal.
>> that was the military one. Everything after that was
like him being belligerent in bars and stuff. He didn't >> Wait,
wait, wait.
There's more stuff
I didn't hear about any of this stuff after except him holding
the gun to Te's
>> What? Then we know >> he did he did he did probably
grope women and stuff and to from what Tech stated, he had no
idea about any of this. And since he found out about it, he's
just not really >> How do you go from not It's definitely
not assault. Maybe something less. He He did He almost He He
definitely could have grew up women. He definitely grew up with
women. >> His dad on stream anymore, >> bro. That
has to be There's no way he didn't know. >> I Well, he's
been separated from his dad for like years. He only like got
back together and talked to him again with when he moved back
to Texas and that was around the frame divorce.
>> Oh, this rabbit hole. this >> see what I mean?
>> See what I mean?
>> It's ridiculous. Like if he if he ended up doing all
of this like Yeah, he groped Yeah, I see chat. Yeah, he groped
women. Yes, he probably ended up groping women. It was kind of
soul. He didn't end up anybody, but he was a very >> I
just saw a chatter an industrious chatter out here. He doesn't
like this guy very much. This guy is a mega coper.
Who's this guy? Who's this guy? at that point. Am I going to
Am I going to say >> what the >> somebody? No. Is
he definitely like a creep? Yeah, sure. He can probably be a
creep, but I'm not going to like label him something he isn't.
>> I um Okay. Yeah, this guy just ran. He just grabbed.
He just loved. Are we going to call him a C? Cuz he loved he
just love grabbing sometimes whether with consent, without consent.
He just love All right. That's this guy. You should label that
guy a That's kind of up, isn't it? What I'm what I'm just understanding
is that this is like gen this is not this is something that needs
a deep dive if I'm going to go deeper on this. But for now, let's
I am I like hearing your perspective, the counter perspective.
Um I'm not going to [__] uh you know >> I'm
not going to
dig in too deep aside from the the gut questions I have. But
yeah, um you're you're telling me that the thing with the military,
because from what I understand, it was like a public case. It
was like a big deal. You're telling me it was basically a case
of him showing
>> something that was like not safe for work kind of or
something like that to >> Yes. Yes, that was pretty much
exactly it. It was it was that and it was in the military and
it was considered bad for an a higher ranking official person
to do that. >> Okay. What was your >> Yeah, that
makes that makes sense. I I think it was like like higher than
lieutenant. I can't remember the specifics. I I had it in my
file somewhere, but because I was supposed to do a follow-up
video to like all the previous allegations and know supposed
to just condense everything. To >> be clear, I think it's
I think it's I think that he had to have known, man, that his
dad >> that it it you could you are definitely like able
to think that. It just doesn't seem like it was unlikely considering
he didn't bring up his dad like at all until like much later
on when he came back to Texas.
Right. So, his dad, when's that? Like 2023, 2024?
Yeah. >> Speed this up a little bit. Okay. >> It's
like everything I've looked at is like that's the only occasion
he had to bring his dad back up. And like he said, and specifically
Tech's words, I didn't know he did any of this. And it sucks
to know that my father did this stuff. And it's like, okay, it's
possible. He just didn't know. It's possible. And honestly, I
can't I can't fault him for >> Cuz he just didn't seem
like he was that close to his father. >> Will you react
to the Nick interview? >> What's this? Will you react to
the Nick Quentes Candace Owens interview atomizer? That's actually
not that bad of an idea. But for now, we're doing a deep dive
on techy. All right, let's get it. I'm going to skip. Well, wait.
Let's just see what the claim is against the >> But it
was so horrific. It would have ruined all of our life. >> Girls
don't like crazy guys.
I had to dig into that specifically. >> Promoting Gotcha
games like Genchin Impact, which from what I can tell is essentially
like gambling for children as companies generate revenue for
us. >> I had to dig so much into this. >> Wait. Okay.
All right. >> Oh, the gotcha game stuff. I had to dig into
that because specifically the video is gota drama and that's
what that was like the core of why the gotcha community hated
That was the biggest out of bad boy.
>> Dad was army. You don't get assign
>> cuz this guy talk about te literally talks about finding
out when he was a teenager. So he finds out. So Tecton's story
I think Shimu was that he found out when he's a teenager but
his dad downplayed it and he thought it was again the email thing
like an email chain or he was showing people on his I don't think
a phone would have been relevant here but that he's like showing
from his computer,
right? That's that's like what Tech says he knew. But I don't
know if that's true cuz Pink said something that seemed to point
against that. Seemed to like go against that. Pink said like,
"Oh, we talked about this before before this." Like how I didn't
think it was appropriate for him to be around like Emiru or something
because because of his history in the >> conduct tribunal
for a silly joke. Sometimes you don't even get one for a documented
recorded act of gang. Father was convicted of assault four times.
6% of all men are empirically. He >> Wait. Whoa. Wait.
Techone. Techone's dad was convicted four times. Assault. Is
that what it means? >> Assault. Assult. >> He was
touching. He was touching.
>> It's such a disgusting thing to do to take somebody's
repeats assaulter and just call them a You're gross. You're just
You're just a total piece of [__] if you're willing
to do that.
>> The tribunal wasn't a soul case. >> Okay. What
is the What the [__] is the
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. The military stuff is not this.
So what? >> We got to unpack that, dude. We got to unpack
that, dude. We cannot be running.
>> I'm positive in the tribunal in the in the Tribune article.
Tribunal. Yeah, trib tribunal article, the article on it that
Shimu site that it says uh multiple assaults like four assaults,
right? Shimu, that should be four assaults from the military
stuff, right? He didn't for assault somebody four times as a
private citizen. That would be nuts.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Sh said yes. Okay. Guy in any way if he's convinced
times. >> I just want truth. I want straight up truth.
And when people state that like, oh, he was like in somebody.
No. No.
>> I'm cooked. I'm so cooked. Uh Jesus Christ. Okay. I'm
cooked in the head. Anyway. Okay. Um.
Yeah. Okay. Uh, clearly I need to do a deeper dive on the [__]
dad. I just Okay. So, what's what's the what were you saying
with the gotcha games? >> Like it's rabbit hole, but the
TLDDR is that you got accused of a ton of stuff while playing
like Genchin and all that. And it was it was like pretty like
tame and a nothing burger which was so stupid. It's it's so dumb.
So compared to what you're seeing now.
>> Okay. Okay. Um like Okay. So I need context for who
the heck Tone is within the Gotacha community. Okay. So like
>> Okay. So he was considered to be Gotcha >> Gotcha
Devil. Okay. So he caused Chaos within a community that's probably
full of women and like soy dudes or something like that, right?
>> Mostly children. >> Oh Impact Impact is a uh you
know Breath of the Wild. >> Yeah. Yeah. It's like >> it's
that but it's that by anime wifers. It's it's that by wifers
essentially. >> Yeah. Okay. >> Yeah. So, I I I'm
going to let chat know. You guys can call me a weirdo. I play
it. I do play it. I hardly play it more than I play in the ring,
but I play it. And um it's a fine game. It's gosh is a horrible
system, but it's a fine game. He was >> I would have never
expected that this guy this guy sounds like a gay chat. I would
have expected him to be like a snowboarder or something. You're
telling me he plays Genchin Impact? Really? I >> consider
Dodger Devil specifically because he had like a character that
was based off Chinese opera. Said that her singing was comparable
to fire truck. um stating something as tame as like this character
can be a support like okay I the community and furthermore any
community that has like a vehemently um involved player base
they can get weird with some of their [__] I'm sure
you know >> uh no I have no idea um the fact that you played
ever in your life a gotcha game bro you might might have to get
>> I might have to get checked for some mental illness
I'm sorry >> queen man you good >> I was having
they're talking about you
>> yeah we we'll put it that But um okay, went up. This
is interesting. This is interesting because >> that's true.
By the way, Queenman plays gota games. Okay. He's played numerous
gotacha games. He won't even deny it. >> I play his endless.
>> There you go. Dude, you downplayed what the dad did,
bro. You did not tell me that he had four plus all cases, bro.
That's insane. That's insane. How the >> the specific was
that everyone's attacking him specifically for the military one
because that's the one that was reported on like massively, right?
>> It wasn't dishonorably discharged. >> 1% of all
cases lead to a conviction. Most convicted do not spend a single
day in prison because being convicted of essay means you have
a high mortality rate. Do you know how much of a psycho you have
to be to get pinned four times? >> That's pretty bad, man.
I I really now I really want to look at the specifics of those
cases. >> Please do. Please do. I wholeheartedly like done
that. >> This guy, by the way, this guy came in and literally
laid out the most obvious disproven one that's been disproven
for a long time. He's like, "Yeah, Frame cheated on Techone."
And he found out about that and that's why we get the uh what
is it? The content resol conflict resolution god clip. conflict
resolution >> We get that clip from from him abusing Frame
in the car. Verbally abusing Frame in the car. And he always
said that that was because he found out Frame was cheating. That's
wrong. That's a lie. All right. That's an open lie. >> Have
I done that? I haven't made a video on it. I haven't like looked
into specifically his dad because when I'm looking into Techone,
I'm not going to I'm not going to burden him with his father
because it doesn't make sense. >> Okay.
Okay.
>> We had it proven wrong from like testimony kind of.
not proven wrong, but like Frame had some receipts that showed
that Kerism only flew in like weeks later, but now we literally
have that in tech docu or in um in the actual court documents
as well. >> I get what you're saying. I get what you're
saying. Um >> Right. Like it's it's like, oh, your your
sister ended up uh running somebody over. Does that mean you
would run somebody over? No. It's it's familial bonds do not
mean familial crimes. >> No, I Yeah, I get it. Like, dude,
no. I I'm pretty sure, thank god he cleared that up cuz I'm pretty
sure Gokaru thinks that if your father's arrest, you are I'm
pretty sure Gokanaru stated that opinion before. So, it's good
that this guy can clean it up. All right, cuz that's wild. That's
wild from Goku. Okay, it's unacceptable. >> Like the the
Okay, so the whole thing where it's like uh Okay, cuz I think
it's the thumbnail of this video. It's like uh what is it? something
like inherited work or something runs in the family and like
obviously yes of course you can be >> like that that is
like a deliberate like attack on tech and it's trying it's trying
to play it like oh his father does it so does he like that's
crazy >> this guy is can't get anything past this guy oh
my god it's like the smoke of the father is contributing to the
narrative of the son being raped as well um >> yeah I mean
like look yeah in my head there are definitely context bringing
that up about the dad is relevant it's like why the [__]
was tone platforming him I think it's they didn't know that his
dad had this at least some of this [__] going on.
But um in terms of I get what you're saying where it's like uh
in in his specific uh you know misconduct allegations or whatever,
you should be approaching him from like you know sober mindset
of uh you know relative objectivity. I get that. Okay. >> If
he's if he's done it like once he could do it again. If he's
done it four times. That's straight up. We agree on that. His
dad beat charges four times. That's ludicrous.
>> Wait. No, he didn't beat. So I think there's a dance
being done here where they got knocked down to assault. They
might have had
they might have had the
element taken off for the purpose of charging, but like I want
to know what the allegations were that he was found guilty of
that he was charged with assault for. Is that open anywhere?
Because it sounds like they were charging him with assault and
he pled down right to to some form of assault. That's what that's
what's in the article. The article says assault. It doesn't say
assault. So, can I see can I see a page somewhere? Do we have
a page that says exactly what he was? What is it? Michael Roberts
or something? [__] is this guy name? This guy's name.
Stop military Michael. What the [__] is this guy's
name? If if you can find it, guys, just send it to me.
>> Yeah. Uh well, I think he did do jail time. I might
be wrong, but um I know that part of the meme is that he was
in jail, but I >> the like some like beyond the article
that Shimu had. Okay. Okay, hold on. No, Shimu is saying exactly
what I thought it was. It was originally assault, but they busted
it down to assault so that he could stay off the sex offender
registry. So, it was like I assault of a nature and they they
seem to have like done a plea agreement or something. They agreed
to knock it down or it was just knocked down in general to keep
him from having to register as a offender. It's it's I just feel
like I don't know that that means good things for Techo's dad,
right? It
>> Hey guys, I'm
not either way. So those women healed women >> that's basically
yes he is aaulter
it's like yeah it might have been pled down or something but
he is a insultter
let's watch this >> and the reason why that went nuclear
because his ex-wife was about to make her alleged an abuse she
went through from her husband te public has denied this for years
that this was even happening by the way >> so is it known
that was about to accuse him of >> no it wasn't known that
was going to accuse him of anything it was only really known
that pink was coming out with it because of her Twitter posts
about that was sub tweeting tech >> wait did you did you
censor out abuse there Shimu okay but what I'm asking here is
even now today. Does Frame claim that she was by Tech? >> Not
to my knowledge. If it's in court documents, I don't know yet.
>> Okay. All right. All right. That's good. That's good.
Okay. >> The reason why Tekk went nuclear because his ex-wife
was about to make her alleged an abuse she went through from
her husband Ton public. Tecton has denied this for years that
this was even happening. By the way, what people aren't aware
of is that legal documentation between Kink and Free clearly
states, quote, "The dispute between Free and Ton relates to a
series of false allegation against Tecton during that ball. Technic
that Free had a Google and she was planning to release it to
the public. We'll get into further detail later, but it's important
to realize that the attacks Pink made prior is a direct response
to tecton finding out through Pink that Free was going to go
public with the alleged abuse she went through with tecton. reach
out to the detective to get his side of the story in any context
I could. At first, he said he was happy to answer any questions
until he realized how meticulously I had gone through everything.
I asked him what the allegations were that Pink mentioned were
going to ruin all of their lives, not letting him know I already
had the court documents proving what they were.
well, proving that they were private like serious private allegations
that or serious um I don't even know that there's like necessarily
but it's like what what are how many other things could it be
or what else could it be is I guess the question. Like what is
the allegation that she took some money to cover up? I hope it
wasn't him chopping people up and keeping them in the freezer
in the basement. Seems like this thing is the most likely case,
but >> Okay. Whoa. So
he >> also give me two seconds. I'll be right >> Court
documents proving what they were. He has court documents
confirming that they exist, that an the allegations
>> Correct. An allegation exists. >> An allegation
is filed. It is an allegation. And that's like the core part.
It's It's not confirmed to be true. It is only confirmed to be
>> Okay, I get I get Yeah, that's I think a legit critique.
Unless Unless he literally does have whatever the >> Sorry,
I I walked away for a second. I had to pause cuz I had to come
back. I think they just misunderstood.
Okay, it's not that he's saying I know this is true. He is saying
I know that there is an allegation. I know the nature of the
allegation. I don't think he knows the nature of the allegation.
It's probably just that it's like it relates to a serious and
false allegation. Probably when you say serious and false allegation
is like, you know, if it's family if it's family feud, you get
like almost all the points on this one, right? Assault.
What could this charge possibly be? Survey says number one assault
or some crime. Okay, I'll explain the allegation part. Oh, do
you want to hop on VC or something, Shimu? If you want to hop
on VC, let me know. What's this? Oh, stop military rape. Let's
go. Okay, Shimu is going to hop on for a second. Explain what
he means. Shimu, you're here. What's up? How's it >> Yeah,
so I just wanted to explain the apart from the court documents
where it says serious and false allegation. So, I talked to like
a bunch of different people to make this or whatever.
>> And there there's like quite a bit that I couldn't use
or couldn't include, but I've seen enough of like the people
like talking about it at like things that weren't public, right?
But basically, this is this was going to be the allegation from
Free. So, Teone didn't have very much with Free or Pink. He didn't
have sex with Pink ever. And in the video, I say he didn't have
with Free for the vast majority of their marriage, right? So,
her allegation was going to be like one of the few times that
they had sex or whatever that he
>> like. That's my understanding of it, right? Bro, >> and
there's stuff there. There were things that like I had seen that,
you know, to me that's that's what the like I'm pretty certain,
right? But I wasn't I wasn't able to use any of that stuff, >> dude.
So, how do is it that the only time this guy could get hard off,
dude? Hassan was so right. Hassan pegged this guy perfectly.
This guy can literally only get hard for It's crazy. >> Literally
confirmed by Shimu. his reputation on the line to say this exactly
verbatim
can only get hard for
I don't even know like for the record like I was a joke >> yeah
I don't even try to think of especially since he's trying to
sue me
or whatever but but no for real like even even like literally
like I don't can't I do not know right and I don't think anybody
like truly knows >> yeah we don't know we don't know that
this happened for sure absolutely
>> it's an allegation.
Uh, so what I was saying is what I think they're confusing here
is you you're saying I know exactly what this allegation was.
You're saying you basically you feel like you have a good idea.
You feel like you're willing to put that out there. You're confident
in that. Um, >> I'm very confident in that. Yes. Like >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> But you you've never claimed that's
the difference is you've never claimed this allegation is true.
You just know exactly what the allegation is. Okay. Yeah. And
I probably I probably could have said something like I have seen,
you know,
uh scream or like something, you know, to where I would know
exactly what the allegation was going to be, >> but I just
I just didn't put that in the first video, but that is what it
is. Yeah, that's what it was going to be
>> All right.
All right. Cool. >> I just wanted to explain that. >> Yeah.
All right. Thanks. Thanks for coming on. >> Cool. Cool.
>> Peace. Bye. >> Troop it is only >> so court
documents proving what they were. He has court documents
confirming that they exist that an >> so I think yeah court
documents confirming that the allegation is real and then further
corroborating evidence that that Shimu feels makes him confident
in saying that it was going to be a
>> Confirmed to be true. It is only confirmed to be submitted.
>> Okay. I get I get Yeah, that's I think >> not
even confirmed to be submitted. This guy actually doesn't know
what he's talking about. The the fan, the Techone fan doesn't
have any idea what he's talking about. >> A legit creep.
Just for the record, unless he literally does have whatever the
that is. I don't know >> if he did do it. I am not remotely
in support of it. Everybody should Everybody's like in agreeance
with that. Nobody's in support of this man if he did do it. But
I'm not going to sit here and say he did it just because of word
of mouth. I want >> Nobody's asking for that. Literally,
nobody's asking for that. You didn't even listen to the actual
thing said in here. You didn't listen to Gokaru. You have no
idea what you're talking about. >> That's what that's the
core point of why I did my investigation. I want proof. >> I
hear you. I mean, I would I would also allow someone to think
he's sus that like two of his major >> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. You can you can you can think somebody's sus, but you have
to have like some reason behind it. >> Yeah, I get it.
>> Yeah. I get it. I get it. Okay. >> Yeah. The court
documents proving what they were, and he lied to me. He said,
quote, "No allegations were going to be made against me." >> Ah,
okay. So yeah. So, okay. So, with Shimu here, this can still,
I think, be interpreted as a lie because Teton's claiming there's
no allegation
um that she was going to make when that is contradicted in the
court documents he has. >> It could be that it could be
that I mean, it could be that he's stating that the allegations
itself were false and any allegations that she would make wouldn't
come to fruition because again, it's it's an allegation. There
are no >> I see what you're saying. Interesting. So, you
think that he could just be kind of like not facing it directly,
but he's basically saying like no allegations were going to be
made. It was just like it was just like total totally not going
to manifest.
>> Pretty much to his knowledge, it probably wouldn't have
manifested because he hasn't been summoned. Like he's been saying
on stream several times, I've been waiting. I've been waiting.
Where are my summons for this? I've got nothing from the police.
>> And he stated he stated at least this could like this
is an allegation if he did go to the police or not. He's asked
to the police directly for it and that's hearsay too. Like maybe
he's just saying it on stream and lying about it, but I I can't
confirm or deny that. But it's the same as like I have to take
I mean Pink posted that she went to the cops. She posted some
proof. I don't know exactly how good it is, but some proof email
she got from the police that she was pursuing a case. Techone
says she's pursuing a case. Why is this guy like, you know, they
both say it's happening, but I don't know. I need to see proof.
It's just hearsay at this point, guys. It's just hearsay. Hearsay
here being that I contradict first both first party testimonies.
Okay. With my own hearsay of I don't I don't want to say that
this happened yet. I don't know. >> On the same level is
Pink stating that she went to the police and submitted a report
and is true on what she's dating. Is Tee True on what he's stating?
I don't know until it's in court, done, and dusted. >> Why
would you have this insane burden of proof for party A and party
B are suing each other? They both agree they're suing each other.
Well, until I see a verdict, I won't I won't I won't accept any
of this. I I won't I won't accept any of this. >> Between
her and another woman, >> provably a lie.
>> Interesting. All right. I mean, there is an angle, I
guess, that you can interpret this as
maybe maybe not a lie. Um, but either way, it is definitely a
little a bit of a weird response, but I get it. >> Yeah.
No, that's an absolute confirmed lie. Uh I think I think you
have absolute proof of an allegation.
You have like absolute proof of an allegation. Free uh sorry,
Pink is alleging that she was going to make an allegation. As
far as we can tell, Free makes no contradict this at all. It's
not even close.
It We do know this. We absolutely know this.
We know that there was an allegation when he says no allegations
were going to be made against me. This was between her and another
woman. as a part of that case between your girlfriend Pink and
your
there was an al there was Pink in there saying, "Well, we became
aware of an allegation that she was going to make towards us
or vice versa, I forget, but the Google doc is referenced and
the the witnesses are referenced in filings for this uh this
civil suit or whatever." >> Yeah. Okay. Nobody can confirm
or deny anything. You don't know these people. Nobody knows these
people, but everybody's still trying to get involved with them.
Everybody's still invested in them, right? >> Well, yeah.
I mean, >> it's Yeah. And additionally, there's another
guy here stating that Tekken's dad did essay. There's proof.
That's not proof that Teeone did it. That's proof that Tekton's
dad has committed it. >> Separate it. Separate. >> Nobody
is using that as proof of the same thing. You were saying that
he wasn't he wasn't convicted of assault four times by the military
and he was
>> Sorry. Assault knocked down for assault. They were assaulted
sexual of nature >> Keep that separate because they are
two different people. No sins of the father here. Keep sins among
them. >> Yeah. No. I I
say that again. >> The sad thing is is Goku is a nice enough
person. Should I say Goku
Gokar is a nice enough person. Okay, that this guy probably thinks
he's cooking right now. The guy in the VC with him, that dude
thinks he's actually making good arguments. He's making a good
case.
He needs he needs a a harsher wakeup call. Okay, I should message
Gokanaru and tell him to pass that guy on our on our way. Okay,
give me this guy's Discord details. All right. I need them on
the >> Do not do not attribute to the son the sins of the
father. They are two separate people. >> Keep it that way.
>> Yeah. Okay. All right. >> Was so horrific it would
have ruined all of our lives. >> Ring would respond to
all this with, "I'm well aware of the many lies that continue
to be said about me, my relationships, and my alleged actions.
As social media isn't the appropriate form to address legal matters,
I'll just say that neither I nor my attorney has heard from anyone
about actually resolving this matter. I won't be commenting on
this further." Pink would even run over how TeeOne treated his
wife in the car clip from earlier, explaining, "Oh, you don't
understand." And Tun realized that day that his wife of 10 years
had been cheating on him. >> Keep this in mind. This is
the day he caught her and Cruz huddling on the couch and realized
they were cheat she was cheating on him with Cruz, his >> which
is pretty crazy considering only >> that's Kerm and that
is false.
>> Okay, so this is this gets uh addressed head on. Okay,
interesting. >> From earlier explaining, oh, you know what?
Yeah, >> that that gets addressed head on like Yeah, that
gets addressed head on and then you know he brings it up. It
looks like that. She just reels it back later. >> Okay,
let's see. >> Understand realized that day that his wife
of 10 years had been cheating on >> Keep this in mind.
This is the day he caught her and Cruz huddling on the couch
and realized they were cheat she was cheating on him with Cruz,
his >> which is pretty crazy considering only 5 months
later Pink would announce that Teone had been cheating on her.
>> Question time. Has anyone ever here ever been cheated
on? How do you react to something like that by the way? Like
are you is it weird? Like I know some people are like, "Oh, you
you're you'll crash out or something when you learn about that,
like you got cheated on." But isn't it weird that for me like
I just like, "Oh my god, I don't have to deal with this piece
of work." >> Tech, as you will see throughout, would lie
to his audience in a pre-planned narrative spinning in an attempt
to dissuade accusations of cheating against >> When did
you and Pig break up? Me and Pig broke up like mid June. Uh do
you all need proof of that or no? Do are we going to take my
word for that? Do we do we need proof? I'm going to do it anyways.
I feel like it's important just because I don't want anyone to
doubt what I'm saying. I don't >> Oh, his proof is totally
too. His proof is like they had a conversation about maybe being
broken up once, right? >> A pretty serious dot they were
really like talking about. >> I remember I remember going
through this at the time like back when the pink and te stuff
before the Shimu videos, but when it was being litigated and
his proof, all the proof he posts is like not proof of anything.
He just posts like something vaguely related and is like there's
proof that I didn't do what she said I did. It's like, dude,
that's proof that you ordered Chinese food once with her through
Uber Eats. What the [__] are you doing? >> The
only thing very clear, no ill will towards it whatsoever as of
right now. I don't really care. I mean, it was made public against
my will, but I don't care. Uh, but yeah, I have a message. >> No,
that's a funny edit. I don't know. >> Said to Jimmy on
June >> 28 for Pink and I >> Okay, Jimmy. All good.
If I wanted to come over, could I or not? I won't bug you. Always
welcome. Pink and I broke up. Keep secret. And I'm okay.
Oh, balls. Okay. Definitely come by tonight. You going to swing
through or are you >> No. One of Is this
>> I can barely read the time stamp at the bottom. June
28th on the bottom there. >> Okay. Yeah, it looks like
it looks like it's Yeah, he's stating it's within June. And I
think this >> Oh, no. The bots the bots have invaded my
comments, too.
Kan, you're your disgusting bot farm is targeting me. What the
are you doing? Your disgusting bot to badmouth me. >> No,
I mean it's like a STD, bro. What the is this? People are here
really defending that pick. Wild. But then again, Queenman's
whole thing is being bad faith. Little rodent with zero principles.
Oh, I'm not even showing this on stream. Hold on. These are these
are my on my tweet, by the way. >> Yeah, I know. >> The
lawsuit angle is just Ethan trying to frame it. And the pick
is defin not a W. Kind of like Queen's content, which is just
consistently awful. Bro needs to find a new hobby. YouTube for
him.
>> Jesus, Andy, >> the W. I don't want to do the
voice. >> Woman needs to find a new hobby. Stop. Please
stop. Please.
>> Oh god. W for pick is brain rot. Full stop. But then
again, Quimman deleting all criticism from his comments is peak
brain rot too. Can't stand being called out. Kenny weak.
It's just very funny that like these people are botting Twitter
and losing arguments had they have no concept of what's true
or false at all. Oh dude, we do need Oh man, we should collect
these and just get Kathy to do a read through at some point.
Yeah, that would be funny. That'd be funny. Like I hesitate to
give it attention to be honest. >> Really? I just find
it so funny. >> Wait. Yeah, but okay. So, you just incentivize
doing it more. >> Uh yeah, exactly. >> Dude, these
people won't have money for long enough to keep it up. Okay,
hold on. What? I I just got mentioned by
Oh, never mind. I Okay, never mind. I thought there was something.
I I had a tweet that I thought was important. Nothing. Never
mind. >> Was like
I think August. He's in his new place. This the current background
of his stream is the place he's currently living in. He did move
out of his previous place around this time. >> Is it good
for the algorithm that bots engaging with your tweets? Probably,
but I think it's a negative sign when you get a lot of comments.
I think having like more comments than likes is like actually
like a negative e boost possibly.
You probably figure that out. But I think that's generally a
sign of like people don't like it that you have like a rage bait
tweet is when you have a really high like comment to like ratio.
like the last year or whatever mid late 2024ish mid area. Yeah.
>> But if I just buy my own Indians to go ahead and like
my tweets, okay, then I think it does suddenly become like positive
engagement again and I don't even need to leave comments cuz
they've left all the comments for me. >> Okay. All right.
Okay, >> bro.
I'm going to do it anyways. I feel like it's important just because
I don't want anybody to doubt what I'm saying. I know it's a
pretty serious topic people really like talking about. Yeah.
Once again, let me be very clear. No ill will towards it whatsoever
as of right now. I don't really care. I mean, it was made public
against my will, but I don't care. Uh, but yeah, I have a message
that I sent to Jimmy on June 28th where pick and I broke up.
Uh, but yeah, it was good. Uh, nothing bad. >> Techone
for real just pulled up DMs of his mod in him and just had this
pre-planned so that people wouldn't think he was cheating. Pink
would respond posting receipts of the real breakup that was in
July. Please stop talking about me on stream. >> Will you
stop talking about me on stream? Stop. Oh yeah, I guess it's
going to tell me. Never mind. >> Stop lying. I broke up
with you because I suspected you cheating on me. Stop taking
pot shots at me on stream. You know the next day we got back
together. I broke up with you on July 23rd. Didn't want to be
your friend with benefits on July 26th. You wouldn't even let
me ride in the car with you and Sophia and I was outside the
house drunk and alone. I'm not stupid and I suspect cheating.
Just stop. It wasn't good. It was a lot of bad. Pink attached
text messages to the tweet of her breaking up with Tecton where
she specifically says twice that she was scared of him. And then
interesting. Okay. >> Attached text messages to the >> Can
I come and get ready for bed? Oh, please Gokanaro, please get
this guy to address his like complete lack of uh complete lack
of understanding of this timeline and how he's just been like
the whole time. Like just ask like, "Hey, do you think Teone
lied here? Why didn't you in all of your research figure out
that Teone lied at this part?" H sure. Okay. I really think we're
better off as friends. I think a lot of what you're going through
is affecting me emotionally and really negatively. I hope you
can get some help and I'll be here for you. But this is just
not good for me while I'm trying to get help. And I don't think
I should be scared of the person I'm dating. It's not your fault.
I just have a lot of anxiety when I don't understand
uh something. And again, if you can delete any thing you have
of me, I would appreciate it. I wasn't mad earlier, by the way.
I was scared and I realized I shouldn't be scared of the person
I'm supposed to love, but I think as friends it'll be better.
Thank you for understanding. When you say scared, like what do
you mean? Like what you think I'mma do? >> The tweet of
her breaking up with tecton where she specifically says twice
that she was scared of him and then she went after his wife and
there was a whole
why you have
>> Oh god. >> This guy upload this guy uploads like
I think five videos a week on techone. Uh I don't know why. >> Well,
he's an ag
because he's awesome. because he's winning at life, because he's
living in his house. He's got all his set up. He's retired. He's
>> logically evil and his his cause is just and he knows
he needs to strike Tone >> He is a He is a paladin, okay?
It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter that he doesn't make money.
Doesn't matter that he doesn't get that many views. He is on
the righteous path, okay? >> He will receive all of the
awards in the afterlife. Okay? He will receive every reward in
the afterlife that he deserves. Okay? W Plazookas, we love this
guy. >> Yeah. I don't know why >> you like you don't
have any context for
>> I I just know that Teone ended up interviewing him at
one point and all Pazookas wanted him to admit was that he was
supporting Gotcha by
playing freeto play and he should just spend already just so
that way he can get it out of the way or something. It was a
really weird time. I know Teto deleted all the videos cuz he's
like I I feel like I'm bullying this guy and I I want to stop.
And he doesn't really bring him up often. Oh man, when uh Gokaro
watches episode two where he sees that Tech's like, you know,
I always I stopped talking about Pizookas, but now I just feel
like I need to talk about how like he's uh he's doxed. That's
why I stopped talking about him before, but I warned him not
to keep covering my content. Yeah, his like full name and address
are out there, guys. Cool. >> He does. >> That's
definitely something you want to broadcast to a huge number of
rabbit fans who absolutely vehemently hate this guy. Seems like
a good plan. >> Mention him here and there, but he doesn't
look at his videos anymore. doesn't try to mention him, >> but
he's he for a while he was uploading videos about techone like
almost every day. It was >> I don't know why >> he
reacted to this the uh oh the the newest video. My bad. Interesting.
Okay. All right. [__] it. Uh let's just keep >> Over
that wasn't good. It was a lot of bad. Pink attached text messages
to the tweet of her breaking up with Tech where she specifically
says twice that she was scared of him >> and then she went
after his wife and there was a whole controversy over that. She
basically had protected him, defended him, and he used her >> I
wasn't I wasn't sure. >> After Tekton was caught lying,
he would respond in a classic manipulative manner. Quote, "You
ever just lie to protect someone, but they make it so hard. A
he's lying to protect Pink. Not because he was cheating and trying
to assert a public narrative." To which Pink would respond by
saying, "He's not lying to protect me. He's lying because he
doesn't want Sophia to know we were still together. I was told
by someone else he told her the same lie. We both know how you
treated me and your ex-wife. You had her sign an NDA to keep
her quiet." >> Sorry. Who's Sophia?
Sophia is his new girlfriend. Okay. Is >> So, she's accusing
They kind of >> looks They kind of look similar. I don't
know. I couldn't tell them apart for a moment when I saw them
cuz >> All right. But strange, but >> she's accusing
So, Pink is accusing
Teone of the
uh Sophia before he broke up with Pink. >> Before they
broke off in general. And Pink ended up breaking off with him.
But like it just by looking at the um the text, there's no indication
of cheating. It's just that she's scared of him for one reason
or another. And she stated she has anxiety, which wasn't highlighted
there. It's just >> I see what you're saying. >> It's
probably a melting pot between a guy with schizophrenia and a
girl with anxiety. Like it it might just not have worked out.
They only dated for about a year and it ended up not working.
>> We'll see. We'll see. Um we both know how Yeah. Sorry.
I'll let it play. We got a girl with anxiety and a guy with schizophrenia.
And I uncritically and unquestioningly accept that guy's narratives
and cast away hers. Okay. She's just a disgusting only fans.
Okay. With anxiety schizophrenic guy. Yeah. No, I'll take your
word for it. Oh, yeah. You seem like reliable. I like you. You're
a cool guy. >> Had her sign an NDA to keep her quiet about
the abuse and told me
So, wait. So Teone AL So you claimed that Fream
was
frame made Techone sign an NDA, right? Okay. And so did Fream
also have to sign an NDA? Like what what >> if it went
both ways? I don't know. I do know that Techone had to sign an
NDA. That much I do know, but I don't know if it went the other
way. >> Like where where did you learn that? >> So
I learned that directly from Tech. >> I see. Okay. >> And
like yeah, word of mouth at that point. I don't have direct like
confirmation like file or anything but he stated repeatedly he
has not made anyone sign an NDA >> and he had to sign one.
>> He only stated that he had to sign one after
Fe broke the NDA. >> Okay. Understood. And here's the thing.
Okay. So if this video asserts and is successful in proving that
Tecton's a liar that those kinds of claims could be viewed as
dubious, right? Like you get what I'm saying? >> Oh, guaranteed.
Guaranteed. If he ended up lying about all of it and I ended
up like falling victim to even that. Oh god. Hey man, I I up
too. Yeah. As far as it stands, it's all word of mouth. I I literally
can't state it beyond like stated this. They stated this. >> Okay.
Yeah. Understood. Understood. >> Okay. So, there's accusations
of NDAs on both sides. Um >> but the only person accusing
the of uh the only person accusing the NDA is Pink, who wasn't
part of the NDA, >> right? Okay. Wait, so you're telling
me that Frame doesn't accuse Backton of an NDA? Like, where the
Pinky getting it from or Pinky Choo or whatever the >> Pink
could have gotten it from Frame after the breakup and when she
started talking to her. That's the farthest thing I can extrapolate.
>> But does Frame not openly claim this?
>> No, I haven't. I haven't found a single piece of evidence
like of her claiming >> I'm almost positive that Frame
has also said I can't talk about it. Has she not said I don't
know if she said NDA, but I believe she said she can't talk about
it publicly. Okay, let's keep going. >> He told her the
same lie. We both know how you treated me and your ex-wife. You
better send an NDA to keep her quiet about the abuse and told
me to specifically go over the car clip on stream and lied to
me and said it was the day you caught her cheating, but I found
out later it was a lie. Just like your many lies used to manipulate
me to make you look like the victim when she was the victim all
along. She didn't even know Cruz till a month later as shown
here. This is how he treated both of us. Our friends saw it.
My family saw it and I'm glad I'm out. Think attached two plane
tickets from June 2022 with Cruz flying to me Techon who later
dated free. This is important. >> What? What? >> This
is this is their proof that >> all right. Whoa. >> That
curs
maybe. Uh but I found >> it's it's an overload of information
on a lack of sleep. >> Yeah, I'm I'm This is But uh Okay.
But I find out later it was a lie. Just like your many lies.
You used me and manipulated me to make you look like the victim.
when she was the victim all along. She didn't even know Cruz
till a month later. I see. So Cruz is the assistant that you
were referring to, >> Yes. The assistant. >> All right.
So the accusation from Pink Chu here is that Bream didn't know
that assistant until a month after. Okay. After I'm assuming
the divorce uh goes through or is filed or something like that.
Um as shown here, this is how he treated both of us. Our friends
saw it. My family saw it. I'm glad I'm having
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. It's a brand new update of somebody being Hold on. I didn't
see this earlier. Believe we have Ethan Klein reading his full
courtmandated apology to Ryan Kavanagh >> front so that
I can open se >> I actually don't know I actually don't
know if I care but this is very funny. Okay, full full apology
to Ryan Kavanaaugh and this is excused by guys. I need to do
this to sue Denims and Casey Tron and Frogan. Guys, this is fine.
This is fine.
Why boing when her picture showed up? I don't know. >> I
was closing one front.
>> It wasn't this. It was uh it was what? This? Oh, that's
the sound effect from
my family saw it. I'm glad.
>> Yeah, it was a sound effect from Goanaro. That's not
even my fault. Inky also found out about the IRVO.
>> Yeah. Um, okay. Sorry. So, can you give me a like a
timeline? Like when the did this um cuddling with the assistant
narrative, when did that take place? Because here she's claiming
basically this was after they were broken up or >> This
specific thing was supposed to have happened before this clip
with the car
>> It's supposed to specifically have happened before it.
>> Slight logs can't really indicate whether or not he
was there prior to it. >> Okay. But Okay. So, where are
you getting that information that basically it occurred before
like she was cuddling with Tekon's assistant before this car
clip? Like that's the context for the car clip. >> So,
Ton himself. >> Okay, we're going to watch this. We'll
watch like another 5 10 minutes and then I'm going to sign off,
guys. All right. Let y'all know >> had stated it on a stream.
>> I wish I recorded that cuz I don't remember what she
streamed like every day. Um, he did state it on a >> Sorry,
I I was I was saying that at first. I was going to like chill
and say like if I get this many subs, I'll keep going. I don't
really want to though. Sorry. I'm just tired >> cuz I was
watching that one. >> 8 hour stream. >> We're stacking
streams. Okay. We're stacking 8 hour streams documented. >> The
pink one is I don't know if the Teetone one is if anybody's ever
recorded it. There's a lot of hours to burn through. >> And
so those are the those are the two primary sources for basically
like this this allegation that she cuddled with um the assistant.
>> Yeah. And the only other indicator that's like a indicator
that's a smoking gun is >> we'll see if there's any if
there's anything else funny on this I'll I'll cover for you guys
tomorrow or something. All right. And then we'll get the second
half of the Candace Owens Nick Fentes interview as well tomorrow.
All right. Lots of content tomorrow again. There'll be more of
all of this stuff. We'll
there's going to be content all week. I have a good feeling about
this week. Okay. The upcoming the next week the next seven days
going to be like a content deluge. Okay. We're going to have
all the content in the world. Meanwhile, Quimman streaming until
8 a.m. his time. Like it's nothing. Quan is literally half asleep
right now. Shut the up. Also, how long did you stream on YouTube
and then how long do you stream on kick? Don't compare it. You
streamed. Yeah, I' I've streamed a long time. You shut it down.
You okay? No, I Everyone here works hard. Okay, I'm going to
raid Io and I'll uh I'll be back tomorrow, guys. We'll talk to
you'all later. Have a good night. Bye-bye for now. Yeah. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Going to raid Io. See you guys later. Bye.